(Andy clapping)
Yes.
Woo, woo!
Woo-hoo, hoo!
Woo.
Yes.
Welcome to the show, everybody.
A stellar program tonight.
Hilarious comedian Beth Stelling
is going to be joining us.
Also joining us, a packed house.
That's right, we have a full,
full crowd again tonight,
because as you probably know,
we borrowed a page from
Major League sports,
and we decided to fill our
audience with cardboard cutouts.
You, the fans, sent us your photos,
we printed them out, and here they are.
We had close to 20,000
submissions, I think,
and here we've packed the audience
completely full, and fantastic.
In fact, it's so full, that
we have a standby line.
That's right, we have a standby
line outside the theater.
Look at that, that takes dedication.
Those are people, we have record
heat, record temperatures,
those are people that are
braving those temperatures,
'cause cardboard is flammable.
They are braving those
temperatures outside.
That's how popular this show is, Andy.
It's unbelievable.
We've got people outside.
It's, we are, we are the number one show
among the one dimensional crowd,
I guess it's two dimensional.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
No, among cardboard cutouts,
we are the number one show.
Yup, we score very highly.
Any interesting people around you
that we should check out?
Yeah, he, I'm not sure
he's loving the show.
Yeah, but see with these two together,
it's like, it tells a story
about somebody made a stinky.
Okay (laughing).
See, he's like "Ew,"
and she's like, "Oops."
(Conan laughing)
What about across the aisle, Andy?
Who's over there?
Oh my God, there's a beat poet.
[Conan] Oh, look at that.
Yeah. look at that guy.
He got, I've heard his
poetry is very daring
in the 1950s.
Yeah,
very confrontational and
he's ready to duke it out.
There's a lady with a fancy hat.
Oh, I like her hat.
Yeah, we don't get too many
ladies with fancy hats.
You know what I like?
I like it, it's like the old
days when people dressed up
to go to a taping.
Right,
what's wrong with you, you dirty beatnik?
(Conan laughing)
Let's see what else we got back here.
It looks like a, either a
paranoid or an eco-terrorist.
I'm gonna go with eco-terrorist.
Good, it's sexier.
Let's see, okay.
I'm against this.
Do you think that guy is
pleasuring himself back there?
I think he may be.
I mean, it's hard with no arms,
but he's still managing to do it.
Well, let me say, I can
attest it can be done
with no arms.
(Andy laughing)
And if you're gonna do it
with no arms, the back row
is the best place to be.
It certainly is,
just 'cause of the noise.
Well, I am just so excited
that not only are these people here,
but as I said again, there's
a standby line outside,
people who couldn't get into the theater,
braving record LA temperatures,
waiting for a chance
for someone here to die, I think.